a crime series has prompted new calls
for the Baltimore archdiocese to release
documents about a controversial priest
the keepers is a Netflix documentary
series following father Joseph maskel
and his alleged abuse of teenage girls
at a Catholic High School it explores
whether Maskull who died in 2001 was
connected to the unsolved murder of a
nun more than 40,000 people have signed
an online petition since the
documentaries release Jan Crawford shows
us how the series is putting pressure on
the church to release its files on
Maskull when I heard what happened there
was no doubt in my mind that Maskull did
that the Netflix series the keepers
begins with the unsolved murder of a nun
sister Kathy sesnick sesnick was a
beloved teacher at an all-girls Catholic
High School in Baltimore in the 1960s
she was murdered in November of 1969 her
body discovered in a landfill outside
the city the nun had died of blunt force
trauma to one side of her head the
series explores the theory that she was
killed after finding out that the school
chaplain father Joseph Maskull was
allegedly sexually abusing students at
the school and raises questions about
whether Maskull was connected to says
Nick's murder to prevent her from
exposing him he said to me if you tell
anyone I'm going to shoot you
case closed stares Maskull Teresa
Lancaster says she was abused by Maskull
when she was in high school she was one
of two women who failed a 40 million
dollar lawsuit against him in the
Archdiocese of Baltimore more than 20
years ago the suit was thrown out
because the statute of limitations had
passed she hopes through a new public
interest in the online petition will put
pressure on the church to make the
priests file public if those were
released what would that mean that would
mean the world to me that in and of
itself would be the church taking a
positive step it's it would be them
coming clean so to speak to my knowledge
the church has never voluntarily
released any documents pertaining to the
clergy abuse crisis
pterri McKiernan organization which has
no affiliation with the church has
published abuse documents from about a
dozen archdiocese and religious orders
but says in each case the files were
released only after the church was
legally forced to do so
the Baltimore archdiocese has paid
nearly half a million dollars to more
than a dozen people Maskull is accused
of abusing in a statement they say state
law and church policy precludes them
from releasing his records as they
include personnel records health records
and attorney-client communications the
keepers is just the latest crime drama
to lead to public outcry over perceived
injustice 'as the podcast serial along
with television series like the jinx and
making a murderer have both pushed
audiences to dissect evidence on social
media and led to re-examination in each
case the keepers series director Ryan
White says the audience could now be a
critical component to accessing
maskull's file and cranking the case the
amount of information that is coming in
now from the documentary the amount of
people willing to speak up makes me very
hopeful that we can still solve this
murder and also receive some justice for
these child sex abuse victims for CBS
this morning Jan Crawford Baltimore wow
it just shows you the power of a
documentary is exactly what I was
thinking yeah see if this evidence
admissible in court now absolutely